哎首先大家了解一下对战游戏呢
它其实有很多的这种架构
比如说最经典的就是这个p two p的架构
唉注意啊
此处的p to p不是大家以为的那种p to p
对不对
我们的p two p是很正经的p to p啊
就是这个peer to peer
的这样的一个网络网络架构
那么p to p的架构呢
其实现在游戏用的已经比较少了
但是其实早期的游戏
基本上都是用这样的一个架构
就是说所有的客人连到一个游戏里面之后
我们可以所有的人去通讯
大家彼此通讯
把我的状态broadcast给所有的人
那个时代的话呢都是局域网游戏
大家如果啊差不多十几年前
20年前
如果那时候你还在什么机房或者网吧里
玩过游戏的时候
诶你们都知道这种p to p游戏的特点
那么现在用的最多的是什么呢
比如说你有一个能通透ds对吧
你和另外一个小伙伴能ds
你们一起想打怪猎连联机对战的时候
唉你们其实用的就是p to p连接
你们就可以一起连到一个世界里面
b41 般来讲p to p现在用的多
人比较少了
很多时候就是点对点
两个人直接联网
对战的时候
用一些啊进场的一些通讯的协议
我们就可以就是说去玩
那一般讲p to p的这种连接的话呢
我们基本上认为就是作弊啊什么的
我都不管
反正你们自己玩的开心就好对吧
而且这个这个连接呢
相对来讲也会做的比较简单
比较鲁邦
所以早期的最早的这种对战游戏的话
用的p to p的还是蛮多的
那么后来呢就大家会发现
我还是有很多的业务逻辑
是需要集中到一起的
比如说有些校验啊
有些胜负啊对吧
不然你每个人都是自己投票
对不对
说了算
那这个时候呢就会出现
我们会在这么多机器中选一个
说老哥你作为hoster对吧
好我们所有人连到你这来
我们就可以进行这样的网络游戏
这也是一种特殊的比特币
这个东西的话呢
啊其实大家以前在机房里面
或者在网吧里面玩过一些早期的
比如像cs啊这种对战游戏的时候
比如说你打那个魔兽的时候对吧
我讲的不是魔兽争
那个不是那个魔兽世界啊
是魔兽争霸这种游戏的时候对吧
星际争霸的时候
你就满局域网的去搜诶
有人开服务器吗
开了好
我连上你呀
大家一起连上你
那那那都是我小时候最快乐的时光
就是说那个我们就这样的
去连接到一个游戏里面
这里面的话呢
其实已经隐隐的有这个专门的游戏
服务器的雏形了
但这种架构呢它的好处是什么呢
就是作为游戏研发商来讲的话
我不需要花钱去维护一个巨大的
复杂的服务器对吧
你们自己作为玩家
就可以把你的电脑变成一个服务器
然后你们就可以玩
实际上的话到现在为止有一些游戏
比如说举个例子啊
比如说像沙盒类游戏
他们会允许一群玩家自己开一个小房间
其实现在欧美还有很多游戏采用这种架构
就是由各个玩家自己在社区里面开发
自己的这个把自己的电脑贡献出来作为host
然后呢其他人找到他的服务器对吧
那有时候官方会nice一点
就是提供一个叫全球服务器搜索
你可以搜索亚洲服务器啊
美洲服务器啊对吧
哪个离离你那个延迟最低的服务器啊
同学们如果经常玩一些steam的游戏的话
应该知道我在讲什么对吧
比如说你们玩一个那个就是那个lost
ark的话
你就会知道你要哦不是losk
是那个就是说方舟
你就会需要去找到一个自己的服务器
在里面
去构建你自己的这个世界和城堡对吧
其实呢这个就是基于这个玩家自己贡献的
host server的话也是一个非常popular的一种架构
它一般适用于什么呢
比如说一群人构建一个小世界
比如说几十个人对吧
不超过100人的
我在这个世界里每个人去构建
比如说那个minecraft
好像也是这样的一个架构
所以呢这种架构也是这种top也是很常用的
那么其实呢就是说其实p图
p的游戏还是非常多了对吧
他就是说它的好处
就是说对游戏开发者来讲的话压力很轻
但是呢很多时候那个host的那个server的话呢
有的时候他会它的性能啊
会影响它大家所有人的体验
但这个事情这个传统艺能就是
这不怪我对吧
我作为游戏研发商
作为游戏引擎研发商跟我有什么关系呢
这一定是你家的电脑和你家的网络不好嘛
对不对
你的女朋友正在下片
所以你是说你跟小伙伴真的这一局
这个魔兽可能就没得打了对吧
这个事情只能你自己想慢慢解决了
跟我们游戏引擎研发商是没有关系的
对所以说p to b的这种架构呢
我觉得是个甩锅利器吧
就是对这个引擎研发者来讲
是很爽的一件事情
但是呢对于更加的复杂的游戏
特别像现在的这个大型的mo rpg
或者一些更加的这个非常专业的
这种电竞向的这种对战游戏来讲的话呢
现在一般都会用的是delicate server
就是专用的这个服务器
那么它实际上一般是有产品研发厂商
自己去提供这样服务器
这种服务器架构呢
它的好处是什么呢
就是说它会在一个服务器端
维护一个一致的游戏世界
而且呢它能保证尽可能保证啊
就是说所有的用户能获得
相对公平且稳定的这个连接
所以的话呢嗯这个呢也是就是说啊
这个架构的一个很大的好处
所以这两个架构呢
其实很多时候你很难讲谁好谁坏
但是的话呢
我觉得如果你作为一个小型的对战游戏
只是一个大家自己玩得开心的话
那我认为p to p或者说p to p里面
你加个whole server
是我认为还是个好的结构
但是如果你真的想构建
一个非常大的一个世界
或者是一个非常高水平的一个竞技向游戏
或者你想赚钱的话
你要做的是delicate server
就反正所有收费的游戏大部分都是这个
当然是这个时间收费
道具收费
这种游戏的话一般用的都是delicate server对吧
你都要在服务器上充值
你才能变强
对不对
但是现在这个大家会骂你是pato v对吧
但是的话呢
你的基础架构用的应该是这样的
一个服务器
那其实呢这里面再多说一句
就是说实际上呢真实的一个网络
游戏的引擎架构的话
它实际上的话呢是比较复杂的
因为大家如果看全球的这个互联网的
这个top结构其实非常的复杂
而且全世界呢有成千上万的这个
网络接入商
也就是说
我们全球有大概几10亿的网络人口
对不对
大家都要打游戏
但是呢大家并不是直接连到互联网
它是通过一级级的这个网关的这个接入
那个网网网端的接入商接入进来
那么每一个人的网络信息都不太一样
其实当你作为更复杂的一个
一个网络结构的时候
你会遇到一个问题
就是说其实这个用户之间
到你服务器的通讯会变得非常的慢
这个我举个例子
比如说我们把服务器假设放在啊
比如说韩国好
那么有可能这个就是
比如说亚洲的西亚的玩家连过了
他就会非常的慢
这种情况是很常见的
那你怎么办呢
其实这里面有一个trick
就是说我们在各地各个区域
我们设置一个接口
一个一个像一个pto一样的
就是所有在当地的人呢
都连到你的这个po上来
而这个po呢我会建一条cast speed internet
高速的专线
直接连到你的服务器
一般来讲的话他直接走一些光缆的专专线
这样它的延迟最小
而且也是最稳定
然后呢连到你的这个服务器来
其实大家如果看
现在有些比较好的电竞游戏啊
比如说像league of legend英雄联盟的话
他们花了最大力气
就是在全球构建这样的一个骨干网络
这样的话形成一个更复杂的一个拓扑结构
拓扑结构
所以大家想看就是top结构
其实不像大家想的那么简单
其实你作为一个真正的一个商业
经营情的时候呢
你就需要提供这样的一个服务
就是说允许别人设立各种各样的photo
然后photo到你的这个服务器之间
建立高速的链接啊
网用户呢它是无感的
他连到的都是你的po对吧
他根据我比如在南美
我是在西亚
我还是在这个这个这个南亚
我有各自的接入口能连接进来
这个的话呢是一个非常重要的一个
网络体验优化的一种方法
ok讲到这儿的话呢
基本上大家就对做游戏的这个那个online game
有一点那么一丢丢感觉了啊
接下来这一part呢我们要讲一下诶
到底游戏是怎么同步的
这也是今天呢我们的课程中
跟online game好像是最相关的这一part
因为这也是online gaming的最核心的一个东西
那么其实游戏同步啊
我们首先去看游戏的分层
大家还记得
我们在104课程一开始的时候讲过
游戏引擎分为很多很多层对吧
大家觉得哦一层层的
我现在已经学会了
我理解了什么叫工具存
什么叫core
什么叫这个这个这个feature层对吧
我们都知道
但是其实这个架构它有一个假设
就是说这所有的游戏都是在single player
在我一个人玩的世界里面去完成的
这里面的话用户的输入也好对吧
它全是放在一个主体去运营
当我们真的去做一个online game的时候
你会发现这个世界就不再那么简单了
就是说我们实际上每一个终端
大家都会有什么呢
都会有输入
都会有各种各样的game states
然后呢
这个世界上面一系列的游戏复杂的逻辑呀
状态呀
他到底是应该放在客户端的
这个游戏引擎的这一层呢
还是应该放在服务器呢
哎这件事情好像就没有那么简单了
实际上大家去想一个最理想的游戏引擎的
就是做一个对战游戏的通用方式
是不是说我在客户端只需要解决
说我的输入输出对吧啊
就是输入就是我的controller
比如手柄啊
键盘鼠标的输入输出是什么呢
就渲染渲染到我的屏幕上
其他的逻辑
我希望最好全部交给服务器来做这件事情
对不对
这件事情还真的是对的
他去做我们这个这个叫地球模拟器的时候
我们这个叫宇宙universe模拟器的时候
我猜他老人家就是这么做的对吧
他的他的物理模拟是一致的
我们每个人只是看了一个view而已
所以呢我们只是每个人负责输入我们的
我们的主观意志负责输入了
然后呢
我们的眼睛负责收集他老人家生成的光子
然后我们就形成了我们的view
但是呢在游戏里面
这件事情其实没有那么的简单
那么其实呢在游戏世界里面
如果这里面是一个我们实时拍出来的
这种效果
就是说你看到了就是自己的操作
和别人看到你的操作
彼此之间是有一个延迟的
其实你们是在两个完全不同的universe里面
但是我要感觉让你们感觉
你们是在一个世界里面
那么就是说这个游戏世界同步
的基础架构呢一般有三种
第一种呢我们先讲最简单的
也是最古老的
就是那个step shot
就是我对这个游戏的状态不停地照顾
照的方法
那么这个的话其实现在用的人比较少的
但我会提一下
第二种呢就是大名鼎鼎的叫真同步
但是虽然现在有人在争论说
这个东西到底叫不叫真同步
但我觉得这不重要
就是细节对吧
如果大家很纠结
我们叫lockstep
对不对
叫锁不同步
这个听上去好像有一点点高大上
不明觉厉对吧
但是我觉得真同步大家都能明白
那么还有一个呢就是状态同步对吧
这也是现在用的最多的一种
也不叫最多吧
就是用的也是非常普遍的一种同步方法
这种这三种方法呢
基本上是现在游戏中最主流的几种
这个就是网络游戏状态同步的方技术架构
先从最简单的这个step shot dation开始讲起
这个方法呢其实很古老啊
从最早的这个quick时代开始
它的基础思想是什么呢
其实很简单
就是说
客户端只负责把自己的收入发给服务器
让服务器那边呢进行整个游戏世界的模拟
他把整个世界游戏世界模拟的一清二楚
五之后呢
他把这个这个整个游戏世界的状态诶
生成好
生成一个快照
就相当于把这一刻把每个人的血量
你的位置
你现在应该是什么样的一个这个速度
什么样的一个一个朝向对吧
全部生成好之后
客户端拿到这些所有的信息之后
好
接下那个
你可以把每一个客户端的小人
想象成一个提线木
那个在那个虚幻引擎里面
有个词儿叫poem对吧
我觉得这个pom这个词我觉得是蛮喜欢的
就是起子好
你就把那个你的客户端
各个小人放到服务器告诉你的位置
你就把它放到这样一个位置
诶
你这时候你无论用什么视角去渲染它
那是你的事
你看到的东西它就是这样的一个东西
就这个结构啊
它非常的干净
非常的漂亮
就是说它保证了这个大家的状态的
绝对的一致性对吧
所有人只是把书同步给server server一片
模拟完之后
整个世界的状态是高度一致的
你不用担心同步的问题
然后呢客户端它也很轻松
他只是在渲染
只是在在最后的一个绘制和表现而已
那么这样的方法的话呢
其实就是说啊
一般来讲我们在做服务器端
那个状态模拟的时候呢
我们会希望他的这个就是说不要吃掉
我太多的这个计算的带宽
那怎么办呢
诶我会把它的帧率稍微下降一点
比如服务器端
我们很多时候说时针是不是就可以了对吧
但客户端的话
我们可能希望更丝滑一点
我们希望是30帧
60帧
大家如果玩个quick的人
就知道那个简直是晕的晕头转向嘛对吧
这个打quick可以把你打吐为止对吧
那所以的话呢这个时候呢你就会发现诶
好像如果我的服务器端的这个
因为你每次照照快照其实成本还是很高的
快照同步条的成本也是非常高嘛对吧
所以这个时候呢我们一般会怎么办呢
哎我们会在客户端那边的话
在两个snapshot时间做一些差值
这样看上去更加丝滑一点
这个也是一个
就大家自然能想到的一个方法
就是然后呢
另外一个很有意思的事情是什么呢
就是说其实我每次照快照的话
实际上是不是会非常的
这个这个数据量会非常的大对吧
那怎么办呢
诶我们可以
其实你会发现在一个游戏世界里面
假设我有100个a i t对吧
每个i t有这个
比如说20个到30个参数
其实很多参数啊它其实是不变的
比如说你在两针之间
1/10秒之间
可能90%的小怪的血量
是没有发生变化的
对不对
甚至有30%啊
百分之五六十的小怪的
比如说它的位置啊
它的朝向有没有发生变化对吧
或者游戏你的激光有没有发生变化
那怎么办
这些变化就没有变化怎么办
我就存一个地府嘛对吧
这个dif的话其实就是一个delta
那么用delta就能传过去
这里面的话我们举个例子
就比如说这个例子使用用的不是特别妥当
但现在确实很难再能找到这种快照
基于快照的这种同步的方法了
这种游戏了
反正我已经找不到了对吧
所以我们就选了这个物理引擎的概念
就是说诶我假设要做个online的物理引擎的话
那么你会发现
就是说它这里面这个作者给出例子
就是说
如果你使不使用这个delta的方法的话呢
你同步的可能是每秒钟4.5兆对吧
因为每一帧都要同步
它其实数据量很大
比如说我同步十次的话
我这个一个staff的数据量
比如说450k的话
我就要让它乘十
但是呢如果我用delta的话
我传回去的话
你会发现诶你只要600多k就可以了
你可以数据量可以下降将近一个数量级
其实这都是一些很淳朴的一些方法
那么这样的一个方法的话呢
实际上就是说他有什么好处呢
刚才我已经讲了
它的好处就是第一个它非常的简洁干净
因为这个大家如果写代码
你就知道这个server端的代码
写起来非常的清晰
然后呢so stay的一个快照下去
客户端全部通过就完事了
但是的话呢他呢就是说客户端
有很多的算力就全部被浪费掉了
因为早期啊
就是大家知道最早的电脑的时候
很多时候我记得我在啊
很早以前看那个有些架构的
他会讲叫tm的架构
就是他认为服务器是算力中心
然后每个客户端只是一个terminal
就是说你只是一个显示和你的鼠标
键盘input
但是真实的情况是
现在在客户端的算力是越来越强对吧
我们现在买一台
用ccr
买台pc
那不要算力太强爆棚
对不对
服务器其实没有像大家想的那么充裕
尤其是你一拖11拖100的时候对吧
甚至有的服务器一拖一外
那么服务器其实算力根本就不够
所以的话呢这样的话有大量的客户端
算力全部被浪费掉了
第二个的话呢就是说server那边的话呢
就是说它生成这个快照之后传递下来
这个数据量很大
因为你如果连接的人不多就好了
如果你连接的人多
你想想看
就以假设一个链接吃掉你500k的
这个kb的这个snapshot这个带宽的话
假设有100个链接下来
你就是你知道吗
你的上行贷款要达到这个呃50兆左右
那就很吓人了
对不对
大家知道有上行带宽是很昂贵的嘛
那其实很容易就会导致服务器那边的话
整个是用筛掉
所以最早的quick的话
我猜也应该也是局域网内部的游戏
他也很难在公网上去连
为什么
因为在公网上这么大的带宽传起来
大家会很很崩溃对吧
所以说的话呢
这个其实是这个早期的这个
基于快照的方法进行同步的一个它的缺点
但这个方法呢
我个人觉得就是说他真的是非常的干净
非常的elegant对吧
我我一直认为就是说如果有无限的带宽
我一定会这么干对吧
因为他从从最基础的原则上来讲的话
它的计算量是最低的
因为为什么呢
是就是说你十个人连起来也好
100个人连起来也好
我对这个世界的模拟
我只要去模拟一次
对不对
而其他的价格后面会讲的就是
其实每个人都有点浪费的
第二件事情的话呢
就是它保证大家绝对的意志对吧
不可能这里面有作弊的空间
对不对
你只能改你的input的其他其他的状态
我决定了你
你怎么作弊呢
对不对
所以所以说呢
而且的话呢就是说所以的话呢
它实际上是非常优美的表达
但是它的一个基础假设
就是我的带宽是无限的
才能做这件事情好
这就是最简单的一种最快照的同步的方法
那么第二种方法呢
就是我们叫做真同步的这个方法
lock step
synchronization
首先lock step这个词的意思是什么呢
步调一致的往前走对吧
就是大家随着这个这个121的声音
同步的往前走
感觉就是大家整齐划一
其实这就是locks about的原则
就是大家实实现某种那个某种程度上的
一种高度的一致性
那么其实这个呢
它的另外一个很有意思的解释是什么呢
我觉得更像我们我们玩的这种回合游戏
打个比方
大家如果下棋的话
它是有一个round的概念
就是说你出一下你的动作
我必须要跟你确认之后
我才会有我的动作
我的动作你确认之后对吧
你才会有你下一步动作
这样的话大家不会无序的出东西
这样的话我对整个这个游戏的状态
就这个game的
因为其实下棋打牌
打牌也是属于博弈嘛对吧
这个game game的话它是有序的
大家想象一下
如果我们研究一种这个发明
一种打牌的方式
大家不需要依次出牌
大家凭感觉一通乱出
谁手快的人
谁牌砸得快
那你想看这个游戏基本上就很难设计
它就乱掉了
其实lock step的话呢
它的核心思想就是说大家别闹对吧
我不管你每个人电脑是什么样
但是大家所有的信息都是以一致性的
同步的传给我
然后我一次一致性的去处理它
其实这就是lock step的最核心的一个思想
那他具体怎么去做呢
其实在游戏的这个引擎里面
当我们去构建这个服务器架构的时候
它的核心想法就是说
无论你有多少客户端过来
你把你们的输入统一的交给我
然后呢我再统一的分发给你们
你们去做一致的sima
那你们得到的结果就应该一样对吧
所以呢我的服务器很多时候就是做好
这个叫信息的汇总
同步转发的这种处理就可以了
这是最简单的locbd
那个真同步的一个思想
那这个的话呢最早的话呢就是啊
用这个lock star这个思想的人就是doom
你看这都是大牛对吧
大牛总是大牛
对不对
就是quick用了这个step shot的方法
诶
杜姆人家又用了这个lock step
哪一个都是经典对吧
而且到现在log step这个算方式算法的话呢
还是我们在现代竞技游戏对战
又是里面最经典的一个架构之一
对好那这个lock它去用它的时候
第一步是什么呢
哎你得itialization
待会儿我们会讲的更深的原因
为什么这个步非常重要
就是这里面给大家举个例子
比如大家玩的这个王者荣耀对吧
大家linuleon应该也是这样的
就是呃我我我我我确认一下
反正王者荣耀我记得好像是真同步的
那么首先呢
唉当你看到那个加载条在加载的时候
实际上他在initialize很多游戏内部的状态
这个时候
游戏里面几乎所有的这个核心的逻辑数据
必须是高度一致和对齐的
不能够有任何的不同对吧
比如说就像你打王者荣耀
对不对
你对方出了什么英雄对吧
你出了什么英雄
那是必须是一模一样的啊
然后整个状态初始化的
是没不允许有任何的问题
为什么呢
这个东西就是这样的
就是我们各自在十几十台
不同的终端上去模拟对吧
我们彼此只能同步的
我们彼此的输入
那你要是一开始的状态
有那么一丢丢的偏差的话
大家知道有个东西
什么叫butterfly effect对吧
就是蝴蝶效应
那么对于这种复杂的游戏系统
你只要初始条件有那么一丢丢的
这个不同的话
那到后面最后最终的结果
可能就天壤之别了对吧
所以说呢就是lock step的话
它的初始化非常的重要
我们要确保每一局开始的时候
大家的状态必须是高度一致的
诶光有这个够不够不够
后面还要讲的更复杂的东西好
那这个时候的话呢就很简单了
那说好
那我们怎么办呢
我的server很简单
我很公平
每一帧你们所有的客户端把你的书交给我
我确认收到了所有人的客户端的输入之后
诶
我统一的把它发给你们所有的人
你们所有人拿到了这个客户端车
这个这是其他人的输入之后
你们同时开始模拟下一站
应该发生了什么事情对吧
这个听上去极其的公平
就跟我们那个什么来着
就跟那个呃啊这个还很难类比
在生活中
这种东西有没有还是其实又满足的
比如说大家一起做个决策对吧
不要七嘴八舌的去说
每个人把自己的决策全部写好
交给一个老师
老师全部收起来
然后呢
诶他把这个收起来的东西
直接写到黑板上一贴
你们看到了啊
几个人说左
几个人说右
你们自己看自己的角色是什么对吧
其实也是这样的一个方法嗯
那么这个方法的话呢
其实就是说它有一个很好处
就是说非常简单而且极为的公平
但是它有一个非常明显的缺点是什么
就是说如果有个同学特别的拖拉对吧
大家就跟下棋一样的
就是诶有一个骑手
他他出招总是很慢
或者有一个同学交作业总是很慢
结果你的课代表作业总是没有办法交上去
然后老师说本来要布第二第二天的作业了
或者下一个作业的时候
或者下一道题的时候
他死活不出来
所以呢在这种这个lock step的最基础的实践中
你会出现一个问题是什么呢
就是说那个交作业最慢的同学
会拖慢所有同学的进程对吧
这样大家那个去玩那个就是啊
我记得好像玩所有对战游戏
今天我有
就是我们所有人加载都已经加载完了
诶有一个同学他是小霸王
加载特别慢
我们就卡了
他这个还算了
我我能忍对吧
你是小霸王
但是我最不能忍的是什么呢
我打的很痛快的时候
马上要上
我要上塔了
我要五杀的时候
诶突然这个一个老哥
突然就这个他的网络混合的东西
就出问题了
那我们所有人就等着他了
那这种现象的话呢
其实在那个比如在dota里面对吧
在那个星际里面
我们是经常常见的一件事情
就是突然蹦出个对话框
告诉你说哎呀有人断线了
你要去等等等等等等
我也傻在那你也傻在那儿
但是呢他确实非常的公平对吧
所以所以的话呢
对于早期的局域网游戏的时候
我们很多时候就采取这样的一种啊
真童工的策略
但实际上效果还是不错的
因为在那种局域网里面的话呢
这种链接都是可以保证的
那么但实际上当我们到了公网的时候
那么很多时候链接它就变得不稳定了
那怎么办呢
哎我们会对这个算法呢
作为一个小小的优化
叫bucket synsynchronization
他的想法其实更淳朴了
就是说哎呀我为什么要一直傻等着你呢
对不对
我设定一个上限
我每隔100ms我要收一次信息
我服务器没收到了
你本金就算做了操作怎么样
我不说对吧
我说我算你没做成
那我接下来我每隔一方面
我就是把现在已经交上所有的同学
他的结果发给大家就好了
那就意味着说如果你的你的操作没有输入
没有被传上来
那是你的过失
我不管对吧
你要么就放到下一帧去处理
要么你就你就把它扔掉
其实这个东西呢相对来讲也是公平的
这个这个其实啊
这个在我们在做网络游戏策略的时候
我们有两个策略非常有意思
一个策略叫做啊
我记得好像是叫网络差者获利
就是你网络差
你反而获利可以这个收益
但这个听上去不合理
对不对
还有一种策略是什么呢
叫网络好者
他有优势
其实当我们在做一些比较复杂的
网络游戏策略的时候
这这两个原则
是非常要花很多时间去思考的
比如说如果你做的不对
你做成了网络差值获利的话
就会出现什么情况
就是小伙伴发现自己打架打不过了怎么办
拔网线拔网线对吧
或者有人专门写了一些中间的那个那个
就是那个那个那个那个啊
一些一些黑客工具
就是说我故意的把我网络的这个p值啊
什么东西弄得特别不稳定
让服务器误以为我是网络拥塞了
其实实际上的话
那个时候我只是给我自己争取
更多的瞄准时间啊
更多的这种移动的这个决策时间啊等等
这里面就讲起来就很深了
但是的话呢就是这个bucket liation
这个思路呢
我个人认为他就是说网络好者不吃亏
网络差者你倒霉对吧
是这个策略
你好
你再快他也没办法
他100ms就在那个地方
你快了也没有用
但是呢如果你100ms你都赶不上的话
那是你自己的过失
所以说呢服务器是不管你的
那么这样的一个策略的好处呢
它其实就是一个balance
就是说其实这里面确实它会产生一些
可能潜在的bug
或者是一些就是用户的输入变成无效的
这样的一些问题
但是的话呢
实际上当我们在做这个网络架构的时候
我们永远是一个tradeoff
就是说我们不会在这种
就逻辑的高度的一致性
就是我严格的还原了用户的
所有的操作意图
和我的实时性之间做一个平衡
那么如果你用最古典的这种
你其实是能保证它的高度的一致性的
但是呢就是这个如果你假设是用这个
就是啊bucket的方法的话呢
它其实更多的是为了这个实时性对吧
打的爽去妥协一些他的意志性
但是如果我作为对战玩家的话
我肯定是选择这个这个
这个就是说这个实时性的
对不对
打游戏不就图个爽吗
我为什么要等你的小霸王呢
对不对
大家如果仔细看
现在很多对战游戏的服务器
它的延迟优化到了20ms之内了
所以说其实体验是很舒服的
我才不要打那种小霸王的那个游戏呢
所以我我毫无疑问会选择这个这个
这个实时性的这个选择好
那其实这里面的话呢就是做真同步啊
大家想起来原理都非常的简单
大家想想是不是几句话就讲完了
很简单对吧
但是这里面最难的一个问题是什么
你的整个游戏的核心逻辑
它都要具有deterministic
就是确定性
而确定性这件事情其实是非常难的
哎大家什么在哪个地方
我们讲到了确定性了
我们在讲物理引擎的时候
讲到了确定性
对不对
那么当时就讲了那个物理引擎对吧
我一样的物理输入
我经过那么多复杂的迭代运算对吧
跟几个雅克比矩阵
简称的结果还是一模一样的
大家想想看这玩意儿靠谱吗
我觉得这玩意其实挺难的
那么但是的话呢
如果这个东西会影响到游戏的逻辑的话
诶不好意思
或者叫我们我们更专业的说法
叫游戏的结算嘛
就transaction
就真的它是有一次业务结算的时候
你还真的要保证它的确定性
而这里面传统的问题就来了
比如说浮点数它能不能保证一致性
对不对
你的rua number随机数能不能保证一致性对吧
你的各种各样的数字数字与容器
比如vector呀
比如说那个list呀
各种tree啊
对不对
就是说说那个计算的action
这些算法它能保证一致性
对不对
你的数学库能不能保证一致性对吧
更难的是什么
你的物理是mation
能不能保证一致性
对不对
还有就是说那个你的整个逻辑的执行顺序
就是因为大家知道就是我的component
打个比方
比如说我们的游戏引擎是component
对不对
come on
我有几百个物体
每个物体的话有几十个con
那我有几千个这个组件
我要保证它的执行顺序是高度一致的
为什么他如果不一致的话
它的结构可能会产生不一样
哎呀完了
这个
这里面
你这些所有东西都要保证一致的情况下
对吧
就保证这种deterministic确定性的情况下
你的真同步才是合理的
因为大家仔细想想
真同步这件事情是不是很微妙
就是说我们彼此是完全隔绝的宇宙
我们只是设定了一样的初始条件
诶
我在用一样的这个输入变量
然后经过了比如说几千次
上万次的这种迭代
我们最终的结果都是一样的
这就是确定性的一个很难的一个地方
但这件事情在
如果你要实现真同步的游戏引擎的话
你还真的需要实现这个东西
而这个确实确实非常的难
这个里面大家又回到了民间科学部分啊
就是大家想想看这个啊
我们的宇宙满不满足这个属性
大家都至少以我们现在已知的物理学原理
我们认为这个这个事情是不能满足的
为什么哎呀
那么一点点的地方
因为什么呢
因为我们又叫不那个那个叫什么
不确定那个原则对吧
这个量子里面
它很多东西它真的是真随机的
所以说它你就是一模一样的输入条件
它的输出就会有那么一点的差别
那想想想我们伟大的三体问题对吧
发生的时候
那这里的运动就是完全不确定的
那在宇宙星空中最多的恒星的组织模式
什么是星团对吧
像太阳这种单核心的星系是极为少见
大部分都是双星啊或者三星或者星团
所以我们知道这个宇宙是一个混沌系统
高度不确定的诶
我们在但是在我们的游戏引擎里面
如果我们要实现真同步的话
我们将要构建一个确定性的universe
哎这么一说就听上去很高大上
我们要构建一个确定性的宇宙好
那确定性怎么保证呢
那首先第一个更让大家很头疼的是
什么是浮点数对吧
在计算机里面我们表现一个二的倍数
比如说整数是没有问题的
但是我只要保持表表示小数的时候
二的这个倒数倒数幂是可以的
14/2分之1/18都没问题
或者他们的组合也可以
但是我让你二除一个30.666666
你就没有办法去表达了
对不对
这个时候那简单的解决方法是什么呢
你要符合i o p e的这个754的
这个负电数的标准
那么它从标准上严格上来讲
它是能保证你的浮点数运算的这个高度
一致性的对吧
这个可能是我们最后的救命稻草
那么好
那这里面的话呢
其实你要意识到一件事情
就是说其实在我们刚才提到
就是在做网络游戏的时候
其实我们会面对各种各样的平台
比如说我们作为一个王者荣耀
你手上拿的是个android对吧
那边拿的是一个ios
他两个的这个芯片的完全不一样
操作系统也不一样
但是呢我要保证
你们所有的运算结果是高度一致的
所有的数学库越好
你们的第三方库也好
就大家知道
就是说比如说啊你那个第三方库来讲的话
其实在不同的平台上
它的实现都是有区别的对吧
那么所以说这个时候我们要保证
所有的数学库
所有的浮点数表达所有的这个啊数学运算
它都要符合我们的这个确定性原理
这件事情就非常的挑战的
那么接下来还有什么呢
诶还有就是说我们的这个
就是说很多的数学运算
打个比方
大家经常在写逻辑的时候
比如说做动画的时候对吧
做一些这个反向动力学结算的时候
我们要写这个三角函数
对不对
sin cos对吧
或者写一个e的多少次方对吧
log这些东西怎么办
你要用查表法
这个数值必须是精准的锁死的
否则的话
如果你真的交给他们
各自去算算出来的精度
可能就非常的不一样
所以这个时候的话呢
其实这里面有很多的挑战
当然这里面还没有提到
就是哦随机数对吧
随机数我们必须要求啊对随机数
而我们前面有提到随机数啊
随机数内页在哪里哦
我会不会提到单独提到
那么还有一点是什么呢
就是说其实啊在现在的游戏引擎里面
有一派同学在座的引擎叫做定点数引擎
其实如果大家是专注于做真同步的话
其实定位收引擎也是一个
现在大家特别热热门的一个研究方向
就是说我们尝试用定点数fixed point
不要用floating point
然后呢用固定定场的整数和小数
它能做出整个的数学库
整个的这个物理的引擎
能够保证整个的游戏逻辑的
他的deterministic
这一点的话呢
也是现在一个非常热的大家一个方向
但是很遗憾的是说
主流引擎大家很少用定点数这个去解决
但是的话呢
确实在很多特定的游戏场合里面
我们需要定点数这件事情
大家听上去很可怕对吧
说哦天呐
我那么复杂的一个游戏
我要保证它的确定性
是不是非常挑战这件事情呢
啊好消息是说啊
严格来讲
你并不需要把整个游戏变成具有确定性的
因为这件事情几乎是不可能
那你呢是把你最核心的业务和逻辑
把它变成就是deterministic的
就是说比如说角色的移动
角色的位置
角色的血量
角色的伤害结算对吧
这些全部都是deterministic
但是呢比如像渲染这个东西
说实话你多一点少一点
问题也没有那么严重对吧
所以说呢一般我交给显卡
显卡那个时候我就已经没有要求
所以game state
我们要把它尽可能地做成确定性的东西
那么另外一个的话就是随机数
这也是大家这个可能觉得唉
这个事情一没有想到
说连随机数这个东西我都要保证确定啊
确实真的是要举个例子吧
比如说你们玩所有游戏里面的话
我们打一个暴击对吧
比如说我有30%的概率
打出一个三倍伤害的暴击
诶
不好意思
这个暴击1/3的概率真的触发了
比如说我在我这边
我一刻这个砍出去一刀
对方的那个状态的时候
我出我能够成功地砍出了个暴击
你在你那边那个universe里面
我不会告诉你说我暴击了一个谁谁谁
你在那边
你用你的随处就是掷骰子
我一直我想说掷骰子
但有人告诉我
我们就叫织骰掷骰子吧
那一样的输入的情况下
支出的投资就是一模一样的
那么诶我这边筛子啊啊
还是这个骰子舒服一点啊
骰子出来它是暴击了
你那边掷出的骰子
居然也毫无疑地翻到了一个巨大的六处
在上面
哇
我又暴击了
你想想这事就很有意思了
所以说呢
随机数实际上也是要求严格的同步的
所以这个宇宙里面这个就是测不准
原理是完全不起作用的对吧
这个符符合水哪个哪个老人家的观点呢
符合这个牛顿老老爵爷的观点
老爵爷当年就在想说
哎呀你看我宇宙三大定理对吧
整个宇宙
如果我知道现在宇宙中所有的原子的状态
我就可以倒推宇宙的过去
有可以顺延宇宙的未来对吧
所以那个时候整个物理学界最头疼的问题
是说谁给了这个世界的第一推动
所以牛顿老爵爷整个后半生都在正在思考
这个精密的仪器怎么去运转的对吧
那么这个在我们的游戏的引擎的
这个世界里面
我们可以满足牛顿老爵爷的幻想
所以说如果我们把牛顿老爵爷
放到我们的元一周里面的话
我们一定把它扔到一个真同步的
deterministic的这个游戏引擎的宇宙里面
他肯定爽的不得不要不要的
他发现这个世界太有确定性了
很开心对吧
所以呢render number这件事情
其实是游戏引擎的精髓
就是其实游戏里面很多的运算
都要基于这个随机数
随机数是我们很重要的一个点
那么这这里面的话呢
它实际上是一个确定性的过程
所以呢在游戏引擎
客户端和服务器同步的时候
他们首先要把随机数的种子给统一不好
而且呢随机算法也要高度一致
所以你会发现诶无论你是windows的还是linux的
你一次生成的一串随机数
它必须是一致的
诶这里面我再荡开一笔
就是那个啊
大家知道就是我们讲量子力学的不确定性
里面有一个很著名的实验是什么呢
就是讲那个啊就是那个叫爱因斯坦嘛
他差了几十个事
他说你们是这个世界不是真随机的
这里面有个隐变量
只是我们不知道而已
但是呢唉后来有个很著名的那个那个实验
双光子的实验
他证明了说这个这个这个东西
它这个概率分布是符合真随机
而不是伪随机的
诶这个我们爱因斯坦通知
当然他没有活着见到这个实验的结果
所以呢这件事情的话呢
其实跟我们这个世界又不一样对吧
还是那个不确定性的
但是呢在游戏引擎的世界里面的话
我们真的有一个隐变量
这个隐变量是什么呢
就是随机数种子
这个隐变量在我们的每一个人的一个neverse
构建的时候
我们同步好
所以呢在游戏里面的这些这些角色
这些pm他看到的世界他觉得是随机的
我们知道那是伪随机对吧
一切都在我的掌握之中
怎么样想象一下很快乐
所以有的时候我前段时间看一部电影
忘了叫什么名字
应该很有名
就是那个头号玩家
后面的另外一部电影叫什么什么玩家来着
他就讲那个游戏世界里的m p c
突然觉悟了
他有产生了自我意识对吧
然后开始跟那个你们的玩家
这个谈恋爱那个电影叫什么来着
我有点忘了叫什么
超能玩家是什么玩家来着
其实我在想
如果有我们构建的游戏世界里面
有一天我们的npc觉悟的时候
他会突然他们会研究说
这个事件里
随机性是个真随机还是伪随机呢
也许他们做完了相应的实验会告诉我们说
诶你们骗我
这个世界里面的随机全是伪随机
它里面有隐变量
甚至他们可以反向的猜出这个随机数
种子数值是多少
并且能够预测预测这个世界里发生
所有未来的事情
如果将来我们的游戏引擎
能够走到这一步的话
非常的兴奋吧
好ok
那所以的话呢就是说deterministic这件事情
其实是我们认为真同步
是一个非常重要的一个基础构建
你可以认为它是一个基础
就是如果你不能保证游戏的state的
它这个这个就是说确定性的话
其实真同步的算法基本上是不能成立的
这是一个很挑战的一个东西
那么其实呢
就是对于这么复杂的一个游戏体验
大家想象一下现代游戏引擎啊
那这个时候呢
其实你很容易一不小心就会写出一个bug
就是本来a这个输入就是一一个一局游戏
大家想想看啊
双方都有几千上万个输入过来对吧
那么就是几千帧上万帧的模拟接触之后
诶
可能在比如说d500 多帧的时候
两边这个系统就有细微的差别
到这个就七八百帧的时候
你就很明显地发现
两个人已经在不同的位置上了
而且有的时候
你看见这个人打出了一个大招
但是呢在那边他打中了一个
这个在一个科幻的那边
他是打中了对面的一个龙对吧
而另外一边他把你打了那个一个空气了
对不对
这个事你就知道错了
但是作为一个游戏引擎
你或者说你基于你的引擎开发的游戏
你该给上面的开发者提供什么样的服务呢
其实对于真同步来讲的话
就是bug的tracking和debug其实非常的重要
那这里面最重要的一个一个
一个一个原则是什么呢
其实你要去不停地去把你游戏的整个状态
把它存下来
比如说你整个memory的状态
你整个c的状态
这里要用到一些技术
比如说你要用那个check on的技术
check on技术
比如说我把现在所有的变量在一起
我算一个md five
一个一个编码把它传出去对吧
然后我会把游戏里面所有的关键的函数的
扩和the parmeter
把它变成一个哈希值存在
那那么这个地方的话我就不停的
就是当然不会是每一帧每一帧太废了
可能每隔五帧到十帧
大家都锁定好
我会把它内存中把它game存一下
这个快照
我也存下快照
这件事情为什么这么重要
就是当我在一开开发期间
我一旦发现我的真同步失效了的时候
我至少可以根据这些memory的快照的check的比较
我我可以知道在哪一帧错了
然后呢我再详细的去追下去
就会知道说哪一步的运算错了
所以这件事情的话呢
实际上对于开发真同步的游戏来讲
非常的重要
但这里面具体的怎么样的去生成
一个能够帮助你去debug这种确定性
这个这个这个这个的
这个就是说login的系统的话
在这节课上我们就不展开
但实际上大家如果去写一个真同步的游戏
引擎的话呢
一定要注意这一点
否则的话啊大概率你会开发很久
但是呢你总是发现你跑不通
因为你总会发现什么地方
有个地方你没考虑到光机意向
整个世界发生了蝴蝶效应
最后结果你完全不知道了对吧
那么其实这里面的话呢
其实在正同步的话呢
它虽然用了bucket这个方法
但实际上我们还是会遇到很多的
网络的延迟啊
突然抖动这样的问题
那这个方法怎么解决呢
其实也比较简单
就是说真正的游戏中
我们很多时候啊把服务器传过来的真
我们会开始几帧
比如说一针两针三针对吧
当我就是说a服务器那边出现了一些延迟
就是他没有及时的把那个针传下来的时候
我这边的逻辑帧
我本地的帧还是可以从八分
你取个数据
你可以认为它有个小小的蓄水池
这个思想其实是非常常见的
大家举个例子啊
就是说啊
我们经常在网上看那个就是那个视频
比如说大家看到的艾伊藤对吧
你们看的电影是不是觉得都很流畅啊
觉得这个a这个帖子从高位看着很舒服
对不对
但实际上你们知道吗
如果你们去分析它的网络上
网络肯定抖得都不像话了对吧
那为什么你们会看到那个电影
非常的稳定和流畅呢
实际上他们在各个节点cash了很多的数据
就是前后很多真的cash在那
这样的话
当你在本地发生的一些抖动的时候
它实际上都会把你给smooth掉
所以用buff的机制去解决
网络的legging的问题
是一个非常经典的一个策略
所以说呢当我们在做真同步的时候
因为我们没有办法规避
这个就是说啊网络的legg的话
那没办法
我们就诶做一些小小的buffer
把这些这个这些针我们把它catching在这儿
那么另外一个的话呢
就是说其实在做镇痛步的时候
一般服务器
我们并不会要求那么高的更新率
大家想想看
现在游戏我们的刷新率到60
甚至到120了对吧
然后我我们一个网络的r7 t
就是将近100多毫秒
对不对
那我肯定跟不上你的速度嘛
网易网络波动一下
我突然一下子增加到100ms
也是很正常的
对不对
那怎么办
哎我的服务器其实就是差不多十帧左右了
但是呢我会在中间插入很多渲染帧
这样的话
我如果发现你的相机在移动的时候
那我不会出现这种当当当当当当
这样一动对吧
我其实这个相机的位置可以插值吗
这样的话
我在中间插入很多的渲染帧的时候
这个世界的状态其实没有变化
但是呢你会觉得这个整个游戏的感觉
看上去非常的smooth
但这里面有一些更加细腻的一些差别
比如说我甚至对一些动作的可以差值对吧
这个人的动作
我可以把它从游戏状态剥离出来
那么我可以让他整整个这个状态
变得更加的平滑
也是一种方法
那这样的一个很大的好处
就是说
当我的这个网络
出现了各种各样的问题的时候
我的逻辑真和渲染针
我的我的画面不会因此出现
这种各种各样的抖动
还有一点就是在前面讲渲染的时候
大家有没有记得我们讲一个概念
就是说哎we think
就是现在我们的显示器对吧
它你的free buffer生成的东西
它的一帧帧的刷到那个就是显示器上
如果显示器刷新的频率
和你的这个巴菲尔更新的频率不同步的话
你就会出现一条线
对不对
诶
但是呢
如果你把逻辑帧和你的渲染帧剥离开的话
渲染针可以相对稳定的工作的话
你就不会出现那种
就是那种中间有一条线的
这样的一个一个问题
所以呢这也是他我们把逻辑和渲染
在真同步这种算法里面
分开了一个很大的好处
那么还有一点很有意思的一件事情
就是说诶
当我们这个真的不做个游戏的时候
大家想想做对战游戏
我们最容易出现的情况是什么
是我们会断线对吧
断线大家打个游戏对不对
我正好在上上分或者上塔的时候对吧
突然我就断线了
那时候很着急
对不对
我得赶快去连啊
大家想想这个时候实际上无论是你的书
我肯定没输了
这我接受
但是别人没有停啊
我的其他的小伙伴还在那一通操作猛虎啊
那这些这个世界已经发生变化了
那我怎么跟他去同步呢
诶这个你们就讲一个
很有意思的一个一个一个事
事实就是说
当我们在做这个真同步的时候啊
我们的客户端不是那种只是大米的
就是很笨的
从那个server那边去接受各种输入
它其实每隔多少帧的时候
它有个kf
就是呢他会把当前这里面所有游戏的状态
我take一个快照
而且呢我会把这个快照呢存在我本地的
比如说内存或者是我的磁盘上
这样的话保证我这个游戏机是崩溃了
我这个snapshot快照还在
这样的好处是什么呢
比如说今天从游戏开始
就现在从游戏开始打
已经到了1万张了
对不对
我中间断线了
大概十几秒
我丢了的丢了
比如说几百帧
我现在9500帧等对吧
比如说我丢了十几秒
这是我回来的时候呢
我发现我上一个快照可能是九
就是9000
比如说啊400帧
那我实际上等我回来的时候
诶
我发现整个大家已经走到了1万帧的时候
我其实只要追这100帧了
我不要去追那个1万帧的结果
那个1万帧的结果
你追着看下来追死你对吧
这个时候
所以快照实际上就能避免
我们每一次从头开始追你整个游戏状态
因为大家知道这个里面的它的
就是整个游戏世界的这个这个变化
实际上是根据你输入的一个积分量
对不对
每每一个frame make friend
这样积分上去的好
那这个时候呢就有一个很有趣的设备
叫什么呢
叫quick catch up
那么举个例子
比如说我们的游戏的正常逻辑
诶当我发现我要追的时候
其实我可以干一件什么事情呢
刚才讲了一个很有意思的架构
就是说我把渲染真和逻辑针不分离到了吗
我渲染成可以跑得更快
对不对
诶这个时候你反过来了
说渲染你给我停了
不要渲染了
没有意义
反正我已经落后了
对不对
我把渲染的所有的算力全部关掉
我就开始疯狂地跑
我的逻辑
这样我以十倍的速度
我总是能追上你现在正在游戏的进度
而且我前面又照了一个快照
所以我总是能追得上
大家想想看
这里面这个策略就非常的重要了
这样我就能追上那个
这样我就不怕掉线了
掉线了
我可以再重连
其实啊实际上的话呢
在对于有些游戏来讲的话
我不仅会在客户端找一个快照
如果我在服务器端
我也对整个游戏的state进行模拟的时候
实际上我也可以在服务器端
在某些key frame都在照快照
那这件事情为什么有用呢
照样说我客户端断线重连对不就好了吗
实际上这里面有个很有意思的东西
是什么呢
就是说
当有的玩家太长时间没有醒来的时候
服务器可以给你一个更新的快照
这样的话能够帮你把这个游戏的状态给你
去set up
所以这一点的话呢其实很有用
那么它有更有用的一个应用场景是什么呢
就是这个诶观战模式对吧
大家打那个对抗竞电竞游戏
都知道那个不能关照的电竞游戏
怎么叫电竞游戏呢
我一定要关照
其实关照这个事情就非常有意思
就是说它实际上跟断线重连
用的底层技术是一模一样的
所以说如果服务器那边把现在当前
前面那个关键帧的信息发给你
然后呢
再把你miss掉的那些选手的input
一通传给你之后
你就可以追上来了
但是大家这里有个细节
就是说一般来讲观战防止大家用它来作弊
都会故意的船慢
大概比如说呃几分钟的数据给你对吧
这样的话你就算爆点也没有用
因为那个就是这个
这个别人早就已经不在那个地方了
但是呢其实大家这里面就理解一下
游戏引擎的底层架构里面
就会说它的观战模式
实际上适合这个断线重连用的是一套技术
尤其对于真同步呢来讲的话
它实际上就是用一个就是这个snapshot
就是对几个关键帧
我们照一些快照
这个快照是照在你本地也好
招待服务器也好
其实都是一样的
那么然后呢再通过就是说一种cup的机制
能够迅速的追上去
大家如果看到有些游戏的这个观战模式
假设你是中途进去的时候
你反而可以看到之前的选手的这个
什么快进模式对吧
看到整个游戏的过程
其实呢这个呢既是一种炫酷的feature
实际上也是他真实的因素
就是他真的是把前面的那个simulation
全跑了一遍对吧
给你看了一遍
那么如果有了这样的一个基础的话呢
其实大家就又进到了一个
更有意思的一个东西了
就是这个啊回放对吧
所有的对抗对战游戏大家都想要回放
其实回放也是一个道理
就是我对游戏的过程中的一些关键帧
存下来之后
诶
我就可以在各个节点之间来回拖动它
就是往后拖
其实就是时间有更多的input的进去往回拖
你没有
就是你只要没回到那个节点
其实呢我就是少少少去计算几个输入
那如果你越过了那个step shot的话
我就退回到前面的那个kfc
去生成我的这个这个游戏的世界
所以其实有了这样一个基础的时候
大家就能理解
就是说基于真同步的基础结构
其实我们做观战
做动线
断线重连
做回放
他用的都是一套机制
其实这就是一个非常有意思的一套体系
ok那么其实呢就是说啊
基于这种那个真同步的模式呢
它实际上还是会有一些问题的
比如说假设有人作弊怎么办对吧
因为最原始的架构中的话
服务器就是发给大家
你们各自演算
那其实客户端可以作弊啊
他说我赢了
或者我杀死了谁谁谁
但是大家知道这里面其实很可能这个状态
他是不听你的
对不对
那么但是呢不排除有人
比如说在游戏里面进行一些作弊改
修改一些必要不必要的一些状态
比如说我说我突然移动到一个
什么奇怪的地方去了
那么这里面的话呢
一个基础的机制是什么
投票机制
就是说诶我们每个人过一段时间
都会把自己的游戏里的状态的那个check on
就是我的那个校验码发过来
如果有一个老哥跟他其他人都不一样
我就知道你的作弊了
那我就把你脚给踢掉
但是呢如果只有两个player怎么办
哎这个叫服务器就比较麻烦了
其实服务器里面它会有一套游戏state
他把游戏的state的算出一个check之后
跟你去比较
如果发现不一样
我就把你踢掉
但是一般来讲
如果只有两个漂亮的情况的话呢
呃有的时候大部分这种游戏啊
其实用p two p的价格就完事了
而且它也不是那么强的电竞属性
但是对于一些电竞属性很强的游戏的话
他确实要这样去做对吧
所以呢这是一个真同步
经常遇到的一个就是反作弊的问题
但这个问题其实难度并不大
真正比较难的一个问题是这样的
就是说其实真同步啊
它实际上啊把所有的信息和状态
在你的客户端全部都有原则上来讲
比如说今天你去打一个
就是比如说像呃这个这个moba游戏对吧
实际上的话呢你应该是有战争迷雾的
你只能看到你自己自己的这个区域
其他人我是看不见的
对不对
这样的话我们每个人不知道对方的声音
我去那个就是说我去那个做任何操作的话
我要用我的判断预判
对不对
但是实际上你可以很容易地放入一个插件
然后呢把整个地图全开
你知道对方所有的状态
所有的数据对吧
因为这个每个人在各地都是全模拟的
所以呢这个如果大家用最经典的
真同步的架构的话
其实就会有这样的一个问题
所以大家
这就是大家
为什么看到早期的很多真同步的网游的话
它很容易出现一种就是外挂
这个外挂会让你看到所有的东西一清二楚
对吧
但是其实现在的这个真正的游戏里面
中同步用的不是那么单纯
他其实有很多方法策略会规避这件事情
但是的话呢如果大家实现一个最简单的
真通过游戏的时候
一定要去考虑
就是说别人外挂的可能性
比如说我们假设作为一个呃
这个这个的动作游戏一样也好
那其实对方的小怪在哪里
敌人在哪里
别人在哪里
我其实都是一清二楚的
那么就是说lock step的话呢
这个方法的话
实际上是一个非常好的一个一个方法
它就是对带宽的要求其实是最低的对吧
你只需要同步指令
那么第二个的话呢
就是说他的那个
就是说从开发的这个效率上来讲的话
如果你解决了他的deterministic的开发
效率其实非常的高
然后呢就是说其实真通过游戏一个
我认为个人认为是最大的一个
好处是什么呢
这个引擎就是说它可以做一些
对打击操作非常敏感的游戏
为什么
因为我们的世界是公平的对吧
后面会讲到那个状态同步的时候就会出现
你现在在哪儿
我现在哪
他两个是并不完全一致
比如说我现在就打你个爆头对吧
我现在就是一个cao
打出去特别帅
正好压着你去打
那不好意思
如果不是真同步的话
其实很多时候这种判定啊
是有很多灰色的成分在里面的
所以的话呢
这是真同步的一个非常大的优点
所以大家可以发现就是对一些动作
打击感要求非常高的这种对抗游戏的时候
那么另外一个的话呢
就是这种阵痛步的话呢
非常好做游戏录屏对吧
大家想想这个技术原理就明白了
我把所有的错输入指令全部录一遍
不就完事了嘛
对不对
所以非常简单
但是呢他的问题呢
就是说诶保持这种意见一致性
其实是非常非常难的一个问题
而且刚才我讲了那个全图挂这个问题
其实对镇痛步来讲也是很头疼
因为他确实毫无保留的
整个游戏世界的状态
促使化是一模一样
大家的输入你的全部一样
因为我是在每一个人university
模拟的是一个全宇宙
所以的话呢这个宇宙里发生的一切
你都应该知道的对吧
所以说
那么但是还有一点就是说正同步的话呢
就是当我们断线充电的时候
如果不使用服务端的这个staff shot
这个机制的话
其实他的这个追赶
如果到游戏这个时间比较长
比如说打了一个小时的那种对战的话
哎呀那个追起来就比较蛋疼了
对不对
你想要模拟多少个tik的操作呢对吧
所以说呢这是真东部的一个小小的缺点嘛
但是我我觉得瑕不掩瑜
真通部
其实还是一个非常了不起的一个架构
其实我们两种方法都用了
比如说我们在做cp模式的时候
就是两个人联网打单机的时候
我们用的就是正同步对吧
但是我们在联网打这个大家pvp对战的时候
是6v 16的时候
那我们啊8月八的时候
我们就用了另外一种技术
这种技术是什么呢
诶就是我们今天的最后一趴叫做状态同步
这个算法
那么首先状态同步呢
现在其实在网游中
用的已经应该是越来越多了吧
就是说很多对战游戏用的是状态同步
就是那个m r p g对吧
就是那个大型多人在线游戏的话
这种就是生活类社区类这种游戏的话
基本上用的也都是状态同步很少
我听说有人用真同步做
那你们的战斗系统如果有的话
那只能说是我孤陋寡闻了
那么ok那么其实的话呢
就是状态同步的话呢
实际上就是把用户的这种状
态信息给同步出去了
比如说你用户的输入对吧
我比如说我开枪了
我跳了
我怎么样
但这里面并不是
直接把玩家的按键给传出去了
他很多是把你的一些指令
比如说我去跳一下
我去攻击了
我就向前移动了
这种状态去同步过去
那么的话呢
比如说发生了爆炸
发生了什么什么死亡
这些东西的话都会去进行必要的同步
而状态同步的话呢
它最核心的一个思想是什么呢
就是说它实际上啊他不会把一个全宇宙
全世界彼此间同步
其实每一个玩家只是提交自己
部分的信息和部分的状态
每个玩家自己在模拟自己的世界
但是呢在这个server端
他会去模拟一个完整的全宇宙哎
这就是状态同步
和其他前面两种算法一个很大的区别
就是server端那边它会进行
根据你们每个人的状态输入
它会模拟一个全的这个完整的世界
然后呢
他只会把部分的信息跟你相关的信息
发给你的客户端哎
这就是非常有意思的一个点
就是状态同步它的很大的好处就是什么
就是说他防作弊的能力要好
那么一丢丢对吧
那么嗯所以的话呢你可以理解成
就是说每个每个人都说诶
我我在做一件什么事
我在跳了
我再我再去干了些什么事对吧
我开了个枪对吧
我觉得我打中我打中什么人
一般叫做服务器判定了
对不对
哎服务器呢那边有所有的信息
但是呢比如说我在这个地图的东南角
服务器
只会把跟我周边的这些相关的信息发给我
太远的信息
他不发给我了
这个时候我想做做弊器的时候
哎很多时候我做回不了
但是呢我周边的人
我想开一个透视挂还是可以的对吧
但是远处的话就比较麻烦了
ok那么这里面的话呢大家去理解状态
同步的话
首先要学几个这个叫黑化
什么叫authorize
什么叫replicate
这几个概念的话呢
其实在且state synation转动同步里面非常常见
首先大家理解server
我今天讲中间的那个server服务器
服务器是跌对吧
服务器是authorized server
就是任何事情
服务器说你不对
那你就得承认就不对了
这是一个做状态同步的
这个文案架构的一个基础假设
那么对于这个客户端来讲的话呢
其实很多事件很多state的有一个客户端
它是有发言权的
比如说我自己操纵我自己向前移动开枪了
那肯定是我说了算
对不对
所以我是auths端
那我呢就是说是我一个player自己的一个client
我说我但是别人看到我的时候
在那你没看到的
我其实是一个什么呢
是我的一个replicate
是我的一个复制品而已对吧
哎这个有意思了吧
这样就是在你的university看到的
我其实是我的复制品
而这个时候的话呢
很多时候它是依赖于服务器端告诉我说
诶往西在地图的什么什么坐标
它面向哪儿啊
你在那边把我的一个replicate放在那
所以其实这个authorized replicate also server
是当我们去写这个state ciralization
最核心要理解的这个核心的概念
这也是可以假设说我们认为就是这个啊
states connection的话呢
最容易出问题的地方在这里面举个案例
我这边本来是个哦视频可以播放
那其实呢从player一角度来看
他是author的短袖
诶
我开火了
它实际上是replicated的
它实际上是他是看见了玩家一开火
是player一把自己的一个动作fire发给了服务器
服务器呢说player 1 fire了
并且把这个player 1 file的这个状态
注意啊
是发给了所有的client呢
除了player以自己之外
但是有的时候他也会发表的自己
那就是confirm
它有的时候会确认
这没关系
这都是细节
但是呢他会发给尽可能发给所有的client
而player作为这个class之一
他收到了
他说好
那行
我把这个在我那边
你的replicate作播放一个开火的动作
然后你就开始去战斗了对吧
而这个时候呢
诶这个普雷一打出的这个导弹
他就开始去模拟了
对不对
在服务器端
客户端都在模拟
就是这个时候
大家没有必要同步那么多的细节
反正但基础的发射参数定向定在那儿的话
一个基础的物理弹道呢
不会有太大的区别啊
反正你看到的轨道基本上都是一样的
这个时候server
假设那边说
你小子好像正好打中了远处的一枚军舰
哎这注意啊
这个时候不是你自己说
普player一说我打中了一个军舰
你觉得你打中了不算数的
是服务器说我觉得你打中了一个军舰好
这个时候他就会给所有人发个广告
说诶你把这个炸弹给我销毁掉了
播放一个巨大的爆炸特效
然后呢呃这个就是说你有个hit event对吧
然后那个军舰被打得很惨
炸掉了好所有的客户端
收到这个消息之后
他们就播放一个那个军舰那边爆炸
冒烟的这样的一个效果
其实这里面就是这个
非常简单的一个example
但这个example的话就完美的解释了
就是station
它的核心思想
就是说每一个人提出他自己的动作动作
但是整个世界的核心业务逻辑
是由server来完成的
而其他的很多其他的观众就是
你是表演者对吧
你有一堆的围观者对吧
其实围观者他自己也是个表演者
那我们只是把自己的动作提交个server server
最后判定你的动作是有效
无效和动作什么结果
然后呢server那边也会产生很多新的一些结果
他会反向的把这些结果
同步给各所有的客户端
当然了
你的动作也会被同步过去
所以听上去有点复杂
所以说这其实就是那个状态同步的
这个思想的核心
那么这个思想它有一个很大的好处
就在于就是说它并不要求所有的客户端
要保证就是deterministic
因为你就像物理模拟不太一样
没关系对吧
最后的结果只要一样就好了嘛对吧
你打没打中巡洋舰
巡洋舰
比如从天上掉下来
然后呢
这个这个这个你在半空中被你炮弹打中
这个听上去很玄乎对吧
但是的话呢在服务器端他认为你打中了
ok你就算打中了
你在每个客户端
它那个巡洋舰的位置
都有那么一丢丢的区别
甚至你觉得那个导弹已经miss掉了
但没关系
不妨碍
只要你收到服务器的一个消息
说你被命中了
你就被命中了
你不要跟他争论
因为他是那个authorize the server对吧
他是爹
你们都要听他的
所以他又避免了这你们的歧异性
那么这里面就有一个很有
所以这个这个c程式的核心算法就是这样
非常核心思想就是这样非常的简单对吧
它不像真同步那么的苛刻
它又不像step那个shot synation那么多
那么的粗暴对吧
把整个状态同步
它只同步每一帧
是同步些关键性的变量的信息
它天然的就带了德尔塔特性
就是状态没有变的东西
它不同步的
对不对
你这一个一个n p c站在那没没任何反应
那就不同步呗
还有一点什么呢
它天然自带的裁剪属性
就是说跟你这个客户端没有什么关系的东
西
它也不痛苦
其实在下一节课
我们会讲一点点简单的这个a o i的算法
就是area of interest
就是说对于每个客户端
我们服务器会算说诶哪些信息你是关心的
哪些信息你是不关心的
就不同步了
所以这里面再讲一下民科的东西
如果是状态同步的话
我觉得也是有可能的
所以我们每个人看到的世界
只是这个universe的子集对吧
像我们人类只能看到什么呢
致敬那个900多亿光年的
这样的一个一个一个一个球体对吧
900亿光年之外的世界跟我们没有关系
所有的信息给我们就可以了
其实所以这么讲的话
又是个状态同步的一个架构对吧好
所以的话呢就是说这是针筒啊
状态同步的最简单的一个思想好
那么这里面就会产生一个
很有意思的问题了
就是说你想看看我是author端对吧
我决定我自己怎么走
但是呢真实的情况是我决定我往前跑
我这个往前跑的这个鼠标
往前按的这个动作对吧
或者是往前走这个动作
他要先同步给服务器
服务器confirm了我的这个这个动作
然后呢把我的位置往前移了那么一丢丢
然后呢诶再等他再回来
我一看到说哦我往前移了
比如说0.5米哈
我这个角色往前移了0.5米
但是这个时候你会发现啊
就是因为有个有一个网络延迟的情况下
比如说100ms
200ms
我会觉得这个角色很傻对吧
这个问题是什么
这叫dumb client problem
就是这个愚蠢的客户端的问题对吧
就是你会觉得这个角色特别的笨
你按下键盘鼠标没反应
过一会儿它突然就动了
你想想这个感受是挺难受的
所以呢这个问题呢
实际上需要当我们做状态同步的时候
这个问题是非常严肃的一个问题
这个问题呢你要做两件事情
第一个是什么呢
你在客户端
既然你自己说了算
对不对
那你要做个预测好不好对吧
我假设我这个操作是合理的
那我就知道我下一步应该移到哪去
第二件事情是什么呢
你觉得你合理不算数啊
服务器会觉得你可能是错了呀
那怎么办呢
服务器一旦发现跟你不一致的时候
你们两个在和解
所以呢有个叫server reconciation conciliation nation
就是说我们两边要去和解这件事情好
那client prediction呢
它的基本思想呢其实是非常的简单
就是说当我在authord client端
我放了一个向前的移动的时候
我本地呢就往前移动半步
这时候等我server来了
消消息的时候
确认往前移动的时候
我再去跟server那边对齐
如果我已经完全移到了
那我就不去动它好
那么其实这里面的话呢
就是很著名的一个守望先锋的例子了
就是说你会发现那个绿色的条
就是我的authors client对吧
你会发现我在我的author里面
我的世界总是跑在前面的
为什么呢
因为我告诉我的世界发生了什么事儿的时
候
到服务器那边的话
我要发过去
他那边就已经比我慢了
等他再回来的时候其实是更慢
所以呢在这个守望先锋里面的话呢
他先做了个策略
就是说他对这个rtt是有个古迹的
假设r t t是这个160ms对吧
大家想这个其实很可观啊
将近接近于1/6秒左右了吧
他说我以前我我去往前预测什么的
一个half rtt
就是半个rtt的时间
再加上呢一个kt frame
就是一个come on frame
一般是60帧每秒
因为那个守望先锋在追求爽感
照新率特别高
就是60帧
那么好
16ms
那我就永远往前预测
大概是96ms的动作
然后呢我等服务器端那边的东西回来之后
我再去跟他去对齐
然后这个对齐过程其实是个差值的过程
它不是一瞬间把人移到那个点
肯定是在下一帧里面我去往前移动啊
尽可能让我们的移动去平滑
我在下一站下一节课
你们会给大家仔细的去讲
就怎么样的去进行这样的一个
就是这个啊这个平滑的差值算法
其实这里面有很多细节的东西
但这里面不重要
就是细节
所以说其实啊
就是大家看到游戏里面
那种丝滑的操作的爽感
你是要用本地的这样的一个预测
才能够达到这样的一个结果
当然这是or watch的自己的一个策略了
其实不同的游戏不同策略不同对吧
我个人看到这边有
我一想这个策略挺好
我想我们自己做引擎的时候
是不是也用一下这样的一个策略
那么其实呢当我这个时候自己做完之后呢
实际上siri那边的话它是要进行一个和解的
那怎么去做呢
其实啊我们在看一段的话
我其实server我一个消息一个动作发出去
从server回来的话
这个周期其实蛮长的
可能100多毫秒
我本地的话可能已经跑了好几针了
那我怎么办
我这个时候呢
就会把我本地的每一次预测和每一个状态
全部把它八分到一个
这个就是一个一个一个序列站里面去
这样的话呢
当server的每一个信息回来的时候
我就会跟他那个过去的信息去去检验
这里面有个细节是什么呢
就是说往回退啊
就是当server告诉你说你现在在位置
这个比如说x点的时候
实际上是server在比如说零点啊
50ms之前的认为
假如你们rt d是100ms
为什么呢
因为server算出来说你现在在x点对吧
其实你你在你这时候已经跑到x一撇
点x一撇
假设不等于x是不是说明你的预测错了呢
其实不一定的
为什么
因为server回来的消息他还要走半个rtt
对不对
所以你要回溯到前面那个饭卡t t
看一下我的位置是不是跟server讲的一样
如果我跟server讲的一样
那我明白了
我跟server的世界其实是同步的
只是因为他把这个信息传递给我的时候
产生了延迟
所以说这个时候呢
你就要你就是不是只能不是
只存你当前的状态
你还要把你在之前一丢丢的时间的状态
全部算好
这个地方听上去有点抽象了
但是呢大家去理解一下
我是一直讲到说信息的传递是要有时间的
对不对
然后呢我们的时钟永远无法对齐的
我收到一个信息
就像我收到一封信一样的话
我其实不知道你是什么时候寄给我的
对吧我当
但是我可以根据邮邮政的这个
就比如说从北京到上海
寄封信的这个平均时间
我会知道说哦
我是7月8号收到了邮邮件
那我预估你这个邮件是7月5号发的
那你告诉我说7月5号我此时应该在河北
我看看我的状态
在河北
如果我的状态河北说明我是对的
我就不用动了
但如果我发现诶
我那时候其实已经到了那个就是天津啊
北京的近郊了
那我就知道这里面有东西可能搞错了对吧
这其实就是so server
可和解的一个一个一个一个重要的点
那么这个时候的话呢
就是说如果我们发现我们我们在那个server
那个时间点跟他的状态不一致的时候
那不好意思
我们就会必须要按照server的要求
反向的去校正我的行为
因为sa那边我们永远认为是他对的
这件事情为什么特别的重要的
举个例子
就比如说你在你你对面有个玩家在你面前
比如说施了一个魔法
生成了一堵墙对吧
他可能觉得在那个0.1秒前试了富强
我们两个
因为我也不知道那个玩家的时间
因为玩家给我传来的数据时间会更长
那这个时候我认为我已经一步跳过去了
但是呢server那边判定我跳不过去
这个时候如果你们俩的状态
一般来讲
大家在正常移动的时候
不会有什么太大的问题
但是呢一旦就是这个游戏世界
因为其他用户的输入
或者是游戏机制发生了一些变化
产生了一些变化的时候
我们可能会跟server产生冲突
而这个时候的话呢
这个处理机制比较复杂
但是它最核心的一点就是说
我们必须要跟server进行一个和解
那和解的方法只有一个
其实就是客户端跪地求饶
说server
你对的
我错了
我一定改对吧
这里面出现一个就是比较有意思的案例
就比如说你面前突然出现了一座墙
比如说一个魔法与魔法墙之后
客户端不知道自己觉得我已经出去了
然后你会发现你身后就在你本地看
你觉得你身后有勉强
你觉得自己特别的厉害
但是呢the server端判定是说在你启动的一瞬间
对方已经把这个魔法相册
你们先挡起来了
不好意思
你被挡回去了
所以说大家看那种状态同步的游戏啊
经常会发现这样一件事情
就是你觉得好像我穿过了一个什么障碍
我的门在关上的一瞬间
我已经穿过去了
但是你过一会儿又被拉回来了
大家想想看
我们以前玩一些游戏
游戏有没有被拉回来的感觉
其实基本上就是你跟server进行
reconciliation的时候
得到了这样的一个结果
所以呢其实这个东西的话呢
实际上在那个server那边的话呢
其实我们是需要一个ring buffer去存储
这个就是我们在过去几成存在这样的东西
然后当我们出现了这样的一个问题的时候
我们这些reber之后的无效数据全部会无效
全部重新算一遍
这个听上去很尴尬对吧
但是没办法
server是跌
你就去听他的
这里面举个有意思的案例吧
给大家举个有意思的案例
就是这里面这是守望的一个案例对吧
玩家本来做了一个快速喷气
往前冲的这样一个动作
诶
当然对方一个玩家放了一个空墙
你就被挡住了对吧
你就过不去了
那这个其实就是一个啊很典型的一个
就是这个server conciliation的这样的一个结果
那么这个在online游戏里面其实是非常常见的
就这里面的话呢
其实又回到我刚才提的那个问题
就是这里面到底对谁不利对吧
到底是对对
那个就是叫啊速度慢的玩家不利啊
那个网网速不好的玩家不利呢
还是对网速好的玩家不利
这里面呢是一个很典型的
就是对网速不好的玩家不利
因为你对这个世界
获得的更新是比别人慢的
如果别人的网速好的话
能够及时的收到server的各种状态
他又及时的把一些新的状态
input输给sofserver的话
那实际上它能快你一步作出反应
所以这个时候就是说给家里换个好网卡
有的时候可能是你的选项之一对吧
这也是我们在游戏引擎架构上的话
这个有意要做的这样的一个策略
那么其实的话呢就是更复杂的问题
因为其实你客户端发出去的很多操作
特别是你以前往前按就往前跑
大家想一下我玩cs的时候对吧
我去拿个小匕首还是冲锋的时候
我是不是一路按着w往前冲啊
对不对
但是呢其实这样高频的往前移动的
这样的一个信号
他有的时候在网络环境下会丢掉
那这个丢掉怎么办
其实呢server有一个非常简单的策略
就是说它首先会把用户的这个输入
有一个buffer rain buffer把它存起来
就是他不会只存你一帧的数
它会存好几年的数
所以他也做了一个小小的buffer
保证server的逻辑它是流畅的
第二个呢
如果他在一定时间里面
他已经收不到你的任何输入的时候呢
他有的时候会自动的
把你过去的最后一次操作可以duplicate
所以说比如说你断网的时候
我们大家经常打网游里面发现一个情况
就是你其实这边已经断网了对吧
你已经双手离开键盘了
但是你在你看你朋友那边
你自己的话是在那边一直跑跑跑跑跑
直到跑到血压处摔死或者被人爆头了
其实呢这就是一个server里面处理
但这个东西呢其实啊
它是每一个游戏都会有自己的选项吧
但是的话呢我觉得啊
这也是一个大家很常用的一个practice
就是还是回到那个
你
当我们一旦从单机游戏变成网络游戏的时
候
你发现你面对的是一个
极其不稳定的一个世界
你需要做各种各样的策略
确保大家感觉大致一致
的这样的一个游戏体验
那基本上的话呢就是讲到这儿
我们的状态同步的核心要点讲完了
因为这是104课嘛
所以我们没有讲的特别的深对吧
那么其实的话呢就是状态同步和lock step
同步的话
现在是两大主流的这样的一个一个体系
那作为我自己个人来讲的话
我刚才我也讲过
就是我一直认为
真同步呢是一个非常好的东西
它特别适合那种对抗
抗打击感特别强的游戏对吧
然后呢
竞技游戏
我也觉得就是用真同步是个蛮好的选项
但是他对网络的要求是蛮高的
那么另外一个他对你引擎的要求也很高
因为要求你引擎核心逻辑
业务确定性是非常高
而且他也非常的鲁棒
那么状态同步它比较适合处理那种什么的
就是网络本身比较复杂
不太稳定
而且游戏业务也比较复杂
另外一个的话呢
就是说我的整个游戏参与者特别特别多
游戏业务也比较丰富的情况下
其实状态同步是一个比较主流的一个选项
就比如说我们构建一个几百人
上上万人在一起的这样一个游戏世界
我不可能把这上万人在一起进行的
这种战斗全部在一起
就是每在在每个客户端都模拟一遍
这个其实你根本跑不动对吧
那这个时候你可能真痛
不是状态同步是你唯一的选项
但是两个方法的话呢
完全趋于大家的一个一个自己的决策
实际上的话呢就是啊
我看到现在的很多引擎啊
打个比方
比如说呃现在商业引擎
就是说呃很多以及缺损的
它都是能实现状态同步对吧
rap cde啊
这个我信号我这边r p c调用都很简单
但是呢
你如果要把这个引擎改造成真同步的话
一般来说都要求团队很小心地写很多自己
hq的代码
然后呢把这个阵痛过去实现好
好像现在真正的就是专门为真同步游戏
做的这种有性情啊
我好像没有见到
但是有可能有可能就是说我接触的不够多
但是很多时候真痛苦的游戏
都是要自己去改引擎
能实现这样的一个效果
但这两个都非常的有用
好讲到这一part的话
基本上就讲完了对吧
那我的问题就是学了这么多东西
我们今天讲了两个半小时对吧
那我们是不是能够做一个online游戏的呢
那实际上呢我的答案是非常悲观的
学了这么多
其实大家还是不会做一款对战游戏
为什么呢
因为关于位移怎么去同步对吧
大家的这个这个射击判定怎么去保证
我们的判定都是一致的对吧
更细微的
比如说这个这个这个一个大型
真正的网络游戏该怎么去架构对吧
我的信息怎么去分布
这些问题如果不解决的话呢
其实一个对战游戏还是做不出来的
所以呢这些东西我们放在下一节课
给大家去讲
今天的话把这个online游戏的基础的foundation
告诉大家了
对我们从最基础的协议开始讲起
这也是啊就是大引擎的快乐
你会发现做引擎
连基础的协议都要自己去架构好
ok那今天就是我课程的主题
最后呢是我们这节课的
这个就是同学们的课程组的小伙伴们
其实团队还是非常努力
非常那个用功的做了
准收集了很多很多的资料
那么另外一个的话呢
就是这是我们的各种各样的参考资料
比如说网络协议的啊
这个就是网络基础的网络同步是怎么做的
对吧
还有就是这个各种同步的东西哇
这真面文章蛮多的好
ok最后到了我们的q a环节
同学们也没什么问题啊
ok这个第一个问题
同学问我说
单纯的真同步不能做战争迷雾吗
呃首先第一个肯定是可以做呀
正同步肯定可以做战争迷雾
因为就是说啊
你在那个就是根据每个玩家的位置
甚至画一个战争迷雾都是没有问题的
但是呢我刚才讲的就是说原则上来讲的话
如果你的游戏客户端被别人破解了
比如游戏里的state的被人读到了之后
那么他很容易写个外挂
把你游戏战争迷雾盖住的
那些东西的状态和信息全部可以拿到
其实这个地方我自己也在思考
就是我相信很多游戏已经做了一些处理
但具体什么方法的话呢
啊我也回去研究一下
有可能有解法
但目前就我的知学识的话
好像我还没想到这么一个好的办法
就是说在真同步的引擎里面怎么样避免
就是怎么去藏住
那些我不想让别人发现的信息
这里面其实有一些方法
就是说其实在有些游戏的
就是那个就是防作弊
它有一个叫加壳
它可以对一段一段指指定的内存进行那个
比如说内存扰乱扰乱啊
乱序啊
加密啊
但是这种算法的话呢
我不知道他是不是足够鲁棒
如果啊就是假如黑客黑客的话
是不是有可能也可以攻击进去
如果黑客不能攻击进去的话
那确实是可以实现
我们讲的那种战争迷雾的效果
而且也不怕别人的外挂
ok好
第二个问题是什么啊
第二个问题很有意思啊
同学问我说暴击不能在服务器算好
就发给客户端嘛啊这句话呢其实是对的
为什么呢
这取决于你用的什么同步
比如说你如果用staff shot同步
或者说state同步的话
大概率这个暴击是在那个服务器端算的
但是其实今天我们我们讲的有一个细节
就是说其实在状态同步里面
就states connection里面的话
有一个方法
就是我们如果能保证
那个服务器和客户端的随机数一致的时候
有的时候我们可以允许客户端预测
自己触发了暴击
这个时候呢先把ui打出来
让你爽到
然后过一会儿服务器那边再给你确认一下
当然了
这里面你如果自己写个
自己骗自己的作弊器也是可以的
但是呢对于真同步来讲的话呢
啊
那应该基本上都是在这个客户端自己算的
而且我要保证算的是一致的对吧
那服务器没必要再算一次
但是我们讲的生动部里面还有一种实现
就是说其实服务器那边
我也模拟了一整套状态
那他其实呢只是做一个校验的作用
没有必要把这个状态在反向的同步
也和无端
因为这样的话实际上啊它就没有必要
因为输入是一样的话
产出应该也是一模一样的对
所以这取决于你用的是哪种同步策略
如果你用的staff shot
sychization或者csonzation的话呢
一般来讲是服务器算出来的
特别是暴击这种对吧
高度结算敏感性的这样的一个业务
它一定是在服务器算比较安全一点
哇这个这个问题就比较挑战了
他问我说
语音游戏和快照同步有哪些区别啊
首先这个语音游戏的引擎架构
现在还是个open question
就是说大家有很多的流派的讨论
所以呃怎么说呢
就是如果你让我去拍脑袋去想一下
就是未来完全跑在云端的这样一个
online的世界的话
我还觉得他真的有可能像快照那样的
一个世界
就是说其实我只是在那个服务器端
模拟一个one universe对吧
所有的客户端只是观察这个世界的窗口
你看到的只是一个有限状态的一个同步
那这里面的话呢
最狠的就是说连渲染都不用你渲染了
我直接推流下去
你看到我的这个视频就好了对吧
可以一个互动的一个视频
那就这次云游戏最经典的概念
那如果再狠一点的话呢
就或者说我做的更多一点
实际上是我是把这个世界结算好的状态
反向的推下去
在客户端那边的话
还是构建一个这个世界的subset
然后渲染出来给你看对吧
那是第二种选项
所以说我觉得确实跟快照的基础思想
是有点像的
你看如果这件事情假设真的成立啊
我觉得这个啊camark还是很厉害的
总是在旋转的
对不对
然后螺旋上升
说不定过了30年后
诶
我们的快照的这个sima zation
又会成为下一代这个云游戏引擎的
这个主流架构了对吧
也是有可能的
ok好的
那要不今天那个我们先到这儿
今天的话就是我们把网络的基础
那给大家分享了
那下一节课的话呢
我们就讲一些网络游戏的
更高级的一些功能
好的谢谢大家
我们下周见